the
second lesson she taught me was
physical strength there's
all kinds of images throughout my
childhood
of my grandmother doing incredible feats
of manual labor
carrying logs just carrying
heavy things without complaining just
getting the job done
i was a huge fan in russia there's
something called bugattiri
i guess similar to america that would be
america doesn't have centuries of
history to where you can go to
the period of knights or vikings
so in america i guess for a little kid
that would be like a gi joe
but in russia that was bokeh were kind
of like the knights
or maybe the vikings the warriors of
ancient history
and i've always loved the the stoicism
the power the fearlessness of the
stories told about bugatti
i mean as a little kid that's all i
wanted to be as one of those guys
and i remember at a certain point in my
childhood i can't quite place
exactly the time but i remember
realizing
looking at my grandmother that women
could be those warriors as well
you know my little boy's brain and
whatever toys we had
i'd play with and i always imagined that
you know
bugatti were boys men going out to war
and when they return as victors home
they'd be celebrated by
the women the children of their family
but my grandmother made me
realize that women could be booga titty
too
but more than that she was this figure
in my life that
planted that eastern european seed
of admiring strength and physical power
and just toughness in that very basic
sense that's required to carry heavy
things
and to fight i think if i were to really
psychoanalyze myself
at that early age is when i fell in love
with martial arts
with the whole concept of martial combat
before i ever ever practiced anything
like
it the kind of sports i played as a kid
with
soccer and tennis and swimming all that
kind of stuff
were very far away from martial combat
but she planted the seed
that when i first stepped on the
wrestling mat it felt like home
and even for the first couple years when
i really had my ass handed to me
on the mat the fire that got me to train
harder
to work harder that was my grandmother
you